il y a une autre question pour lequel il
y a aussi une un élément
de dire de de narration si on peut dire
qui n'est pas exactement sérieuse les
entreprises pétrolières disent qu'elles
peuvent arriver à la neutralité carbone
parce que elles vont pouvoir
capturer leurs émissions au moment de la
production au moment des premier moment
de l'extraction et de la production
euh en réalité quand on regarde les
chiffres il y a eu un rapport de l'IPCC
enfin du GC c'est ancien et c'est c'est
remis enfin avec des données récentes ne
peuvent représenter qu'une très petite
partie on peut capturer et stocker
puisque c'est finidemement il faut
garder ensuite le carbone dans le sol
euh ou là où on peut le soer et c'est
une très petite partie donc il y a il y
a une
une non réalisme dans les plans de
décarbonation de ces entreprises pour
lequel il y a pas il y a pas eu de de
pour l'instant de d'évaluation sérieuse
au plan de la politique publique sur ce
cette idée que les émissions pouvaient
être supprimées du secteur pétrolier
c'est toute la discussion d'aujourd'hui
qui va qui a lieu cette année qui aura
lieu l'année prochaine pour montrer que
ça n'est pas une solution et d'ailleurs
ça fera partie du débat du du 13 et 14
février de l'agence internationale pour
l'énergie